Oh ho ho!
Color palette-
(heavy sarcasm)
That made a massive difference.
[ bouncy noise ]
Hi, my name is Grace Helbig, if you did not know, now you know. Your life is different now!
You see the title of this video, you get it.
I made a video like this in the past of why I can't be a teacher-
-to me, very accurate.
So I decided to make another one: why I can't be a guy.
But the real reason that this is happening, is 'cause I shot a video over at clever TV earlier this morning,
and they did full guy transformation prosthetics and makeup on me,
and I didn't want to let that go to waste.
And that's how this idea was born.
Now that I'm like, talking this through, I know there's gonna be...
people offended.
These are sweeping generalizations and shallow stereotypes,
so I hope that you know this is light-hearted.
Just know it's supposed to be funny and self-deprecating on me.
There's no ill intention here at all, whatsoever. Please just keep that in mind
Phew! What a way to start a comedy video.
All good comedy starts with a long list of trigger warnings.
I'm not very handy or like mechanically savvy.
*buckles seatbelt*
[ engine turns over but car doesn't start ]
Car won't start.
Gotta burn it.
I'm not strong physically.
Dammit! x5
Or emotionally.
(whimpers) It won't open!
[ fizz of can opening ] Yay!
I am NOT courageous or brave.
[ glass shatters ]
[ door opens ]
Someone's in the house.
[ footsteps ]
Excuse me, could you please leave?
Or you just take a- you could take the TV.
I don't think I could do the..
...part.
Are you sure this isn't gonna like, stab you a whole bunch?
I have terrible aim.
Ah it's everywhere! It's going everywhere. It's all over the seat. It's everywhere.
I wouldn't have self-control.
[ rummaging noises ]
Damn it.
Not the best watcher of sports.
Go guy! Good toss! Supposed to kick it...oh.
They're just all hugging each other a lot.
Go! Or don't, I don't know.
This is too boring! Yay, commercial!
Can't, don't want to, and won't sexualize women.
[ off screen female ]
Like my equal?
Well there you go guys. There are some gross generalizations and stereotypes on why I can't be a guy.
Although just a quick take-away lesson men:
Please be kind to women.
If you liked this video, give it a thumbs up and make sure you subscribe to this YouTube channel.
I make videos Monday, Wednesday, and Friday...sometimes.
Click that bell notification, so you get notified when it really does happen.
Leave a comment down below on why you couldn't be a thing.
Other than that I don't know.
Excuse me! Uh, my eyes are... down here.
This is a sweatshirt, that I am now selling on Represent.com/IDontKnow
*gasps* You can get it in red,
you can get it in green, you can get it in gray, you can get it in navy blue.
Link is in the description below. It's a limited flash sale.
This might be my favorite design that I've made with represent.
I hope you guys enjoy it. Please go check it out if you're interested,
they make great gifts for the holiday season!
These will be here before Christmas.
I think. Don't hold me to that.
Let's just all assume. You know happens you- when you assume? You get 'ass'.
Can't get a boner!
That's not what boners look like.
This is horrifying! I look like Charles Manson. Oh my god!
This is a bonus reason: I would just be diddling all damn day.
Ouch! My boner hurts.